what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 4 of the deep learning with Python
tensorflow and Kaos tutorial series in
this video and the next video what we're
doing is talking about how we can
analyze and optimize our models using
tensor board now tensor board is a way
for us to visualize basically the
training of our model over time and
basically you're mostly going to be
using this to watch things like accuracy
versus validation accuracy and loss
versus validation loss but there's also
some more tricky tricky things that we
can do that maybe we'll cover more in
time but the idea of tensor board is to
just kind of help you shed some light on
what's going on in your model so with
that let's go ahead and get started the
first thing that you might notice is I'm
just adding these two lines in here it's
really not important for this tutorial
but if you're curious you can do this
and this is basically so like any model
even small models are gonna try to hog a
hundred percent of your vram so but if
you wanted to run like multiple models
at the exact same time you could specify
a fraction of your GPU that you want
that model to take up in this case a
third mostly I'm just doing this so when
I rerun a model sometimes it takes a
minute for whatever reason especially if
I'm using like sublime or something like
that it just takes a minute to clear out
the the vram so anyways and then when
I'm recording I've just got no more
space left in things crash but but also
if you're trying to run multiple models
like with the Python plays GTA series
and stuff like that this was super
useful so we could run many models on
the same GPU at the same time like an
object detection and the self driving so
on so just a little tip if you find
yourself needing that anyway let's get
started so the first thing I want to go
ahead and do is also a little bit of
housekeeping we need an activation
function after this dense layer it was
kind of silly of me to forget that
someone pointed that out and yeah that's
definitely gonna be very problematic
basically without the activation
function it becomes like a linear
activation function which is pretty much
useless in this case if anything is
probably causing trouble like we're
definitely not trying to do any sort of
regression or anything like that so
doing that right before the dense layer
out
so we don't really want to do that so
let's go ahead and save this and even
and with just that change we should find
that accuracy is quite a bit better now
I'm going to let that run and then I'm
gonna pop on over to the tensorflow
documentation for the various Karis
callbacks so the way that we can
interface with tensor board is with a
Karass callback in specifically we're
going for the tensor board one but take
note of the other ones that exist here
there's quite a few
you can early stop based on parameters
you can change you can do like a
learning rate scheduler you can also
reduce a learning rate when things
plateau trying to think if there's
anything else the the model checkpoint I
forget if I point out it's early in the
morning everybody
anyway model check point that's super
useful so you can actually checkpoint a
model like as its training so this is
super useful like if you've got a model
and you don't know how many pox to do
and you don't want to like over train
the model right so you might say okay a
hundred epochs or 50 epochs and you know
it's probably gonna max out around
somewhere between ten and twenty but
what you can do with the model
checkpoint is you can save based on a
very like various parameters so you can
save on the best loss it's ever seen or
the best validation accuracy and so on
so super useful but anyways right now
what we're looking at is tensor forward
so with this tensor board callback we
can save based on the the various
parameters for now we're just gonna
focus on log Durer that's it you're not
going to touch any of these other
parameters but they're pretty cool and
maybe at the end of the next video I'll
briefly touch on some of these but
anyways let's move this over here and
let's get started so the first thing
that we want to go ahead and do is bring
in tensor board and so we're gonna go
from tensor flow dot Karen's don't
callbacks we want to import import
tensor board
okay so we've brought that in and I just
want to point out validation accuracy 72
and then in sample accuracy basically
said
so much better than before and again
that was only three epochs right yeah
anyways okay so once we've done that the
next thing that we want to do is we're
going to be trying to Train
at least we're gonna train a new model
and then also anytime you're using
tensor board it's just a good idea to
give your model a useful name so like in
this case we might call our model you
know 2 times 64 confident or you know
something like that that lets us know
what model was that again because you're
gonna train a bunch of different models
so I'm just going to come up to the very
tippity-top here and I'm gonna say name
equals and then we're just gonna call
this cat's first dog CNN 64 by 2 good
enough and then I'm gonna go ahead and
add one more little parameter here to
have four minutes we don't have time yet
but time that time and in fact let's go
ahead and convert that to an INT time
dot time now the reason why I want to do
this is sometimes you'll either forget
to change the name or you'll just train
that model again for whatever reason and
it's useful to have the timestamp in
there because that just makes it totally
unique so you don't end up overriding a
model and worse if they have the exact
same name you're not really overwriting
you're actually appending so it'll do
this like funky zigzag in the graph and
you just you don't want that so we've
got a name I'm gonna zoom in a little
bit just make things easier also let's
make some more space okay
once you've got the name now we're ready
to specify the actual callback object
itself so tensor bull tensor board is
going to equal and it's a tensor board
object and then we're gonna say these
wherever we want that log der to be I'm
gonna say logs select slash and then dot
formats name one of these days I really
need to get into those the F strings is
the latest way to format strings I think
anyway I am
this is a little outdated but forgive me
so once we've got that callback defined
and also keep do take in mind you you
could customize these callbacks or
create your own callbacks and maybe one
of these is the parent class and then
you're gonna modify it somewhat so you
can do all kinds of funky stuff with
this so just keep that in mind
once you've got it all you need to do is
pass it into your fitment and the way
that we do that is by passing in
callbacks equals and this is a list so
it's a list of all your callbacks in our
case we just have the one tensor board
so I'm gonna paste that in fix my
styling there save and let's go ahead
and run that and in fact I think what
we'll do is we'll run for 10 EP aux I'll
go ahead and save it hopefully we don't
crash the video as this goes type air in
it eyes it log underscore Durer probably
yeah log on underscore Durer's the
parameter there let's try one more time
we must you alright looks good we are
training okay so as we train you should
now have a new directory right here
called logs and if we click on that we
can see others are our model right now
so to view it as it's going you want to
open up your command window either a
terminal or command prompt rather in at
least our windows the way you do this
and you can just type CMD from there
just make sure you're in that main
directory right so you're in the
directory that houses logs now to get
tents of board running just type tensor
board - - log dirt law locker equals and
then logs what if that has an underscore
to it yeah okay that must be why I
didn't do the underscore okay
so then it says okay it's running at
this address so you can just like copy
and paste that address if you want into
a browser or you could just manually
type it if it's as simple as mine was
it looks like mine for whatever reason
let's see
logs more logs or logs for some reason
mine is not showing up deep learning
basics logs I'm looking at the log there
wonder if I'm running another ten
support now hmm let me break this tensor
for log dirt equals let's try without
the quotes I don't think that'll change
it sometimes it can be picky but I don't
think that's gonna be it no maybe that
was it
anyway on Windows it can get kind of
finicky on you that's weird
anyway so no quotes on Windows sorry
about that for a while you had to
specify like a little variable to is
very annoying okay so there's our model
all nice and done and you know so
basically what you can do first of all
is see I think this is just simple ray
gags yeah so so what we can do is we can
just do this and we can visualize all
the graphs together so let's do this so
here you've got your in sample accuracy
and you've got your in sample loss and
then over here you've got your
out-of-sample accuracy and your
out-of-sample loss and what you're
hoping for is that in both cases
accuracy goes up loss goes down now when
we see something happening like this we
can clearly see after the fifth epoch
validation loss starts creeping back up
interestingly enough the validation
accuracies still improved about two
points but it's questionable whether or
not this is actually better it probably
is because that's out-of-sample it'd be
nice if we had a much much maybe a
larger out-of-sample but eventually as
this creeps up its this will eventually
fall like if we did maybe 20 epochs now
the question you might ask is well why
why after what why is this happening
well the model is only getting the you
know in sample training data so at some
point it goes from generalizing and in
really seeing patterns to memorizing all
of the input samples or many of the
input
samples so so what you're gonna want to
do is watch always validation loss at
least for me when I'm like evaluating a
model I'm looking almost purely at
validation loss and really nothing else
so now what you could do is you could
begin to kind of change things up so for
example we could do one we could do a
model without this dense layer at all so
let's go ahead and just remove the dense
layer and this time let's do let's do
twenty epochs I don't know if I'm gonna
let it finish this might take a while I
don't want to just run up a bunch of oh
we ran out of memory fabulous no okay so
it crashed okay let's see here hopefully
that didn't kill my recording I will
find out I'm gonna be very angry if that
killed me so what were we on tensor
let's see I gotta find this stupid file
that we were working on so I think it
didn't even close after all that -
alright twenty epochs okay
we'll try it let me try to run out one
more time it's a stupid recording at the
same time also maybe in the future I'll
run via the console for some reason the
sublime doesn't want to like clear away
even though you've cancelled it and
you're done it just doesn't want to
clear it away so that's kind of annoying
okay so as that's running tensor board
is still up I have no idea what I do
with it maybe it crashed I don't know
where I put it
I'll just open another one I guess HPC
okay so here is the next model in
training I wonder do we save that we
didn't want that's looking really
similar yeah okay
no no dents layer
interesting all right we're actually
doing worse you probably also would have
wanted to update the name to be like no
dents or something like that just keep
that in mind you always want to be
thinking about that also why is our
regular expression suddenly not working
how about any word there or any letter
okay so here we have at ten at the tenth
epoch see we're still in samples worse
out-of-sample is actually slightly
better in most cases which is curious
and the loss seems to be doing much much
better we made it you know basically to
ten epochs without without too much
issue let's refresh again this normally
we'll do it every like 60 seconds or
ninety or something like that okay we're
done okay so we can see here the
validation accuracy kind of starts to
plateau which makes sense because after
the eighth epoch in this case it starts
creeping up we can also see in general
loss was kind of worse than in sample
but out-of-sample loss was better so
again personally I would say without the
dense layer is clearly victorious
because I'm I'm more interested in
what's going on with the out-of-sample
than I am in the in sample because this
is just too easy to cheat on the
in-sample like you can always like it's
almost like the better the in sample
looks to the out-of-sample like that's
clearly the worse the model is like that
that means over fitment is occurring so
this is what I tend to look for just
just for some other quick notes like if
you just wanted to look at one you could
check or uncheck or you can also like
just click this like if you had like 50
you could click just one quickly you can
toggle all runs down here this is the
smoothing so as you can see there's like
these like subtle lines out here no clue
what what just happened there I think
our sums wrong actually oh yeah I don't
the graph definitely broke for a minute
anyway you can change the smoothing so
this would be like no smoothing so it's
very raw and you can see how jaggedy
everything is and then or you can add
just like a ton of smoothing to really
smooth things out
I'm trying to think there's anything
else then if you add like a bunch like
like for example if you only wanted to
find your 64 by 2 models you could type
that in but in this case we only have
that many but let's say you want the run
at 344 it should just find ya that that
one specific for example so you can do
stuff like that - you know filter
through a bunch of a bunch of models ok
I think that's enough for now in the
next tutorial we're going to talk about
optimizing a model because we could go
back and forth and manually do things
then rerun things and do things again
but it's going to be much more simple -
to just kind of automate that entire
process as well so that's what we're
gonna be talking about in the next
tutorial if you've got questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below also we have a
discourse just discord dot G G slash
Centex come in there hang out with us
chat with us ask questions whatever
otherwise I will see you in the next
video